[Música]
bienvenidos 2 a 5 minutos con este 11 de
marzo se cumple un año desde que la oms
se hizo la declaración mundial de la
emergencia sanitaria por el nuevo
coronavirus 365 días en pandemia que le
cambiaron la vida a toda la humanidad
para hablar sobre cómo han sido este año
nos acompaña el doctor de carlos eduardo
pérez asesor científico de france 24 y
médico infectólogo de la universidad
nacional de colombia doctor buenos días
gracias por acompañarnos usted ha estado
durante todo este año en la primera
línea de atención desde una clínica en
colombia cuál es su mayor aprendizaje
desde que vio llegar a los primeros
pacientes con kobe a hoy
ha sido un cambio impresionante en la
vida profesional primero por el gran
reto de una enfermedad que uno no conoce
ir ajustando el tratamiento y la mejor
atención con el tiempo segundo pues la
incapacidad de poder hacer algo que en
algún momento no sabemos qué hacer y lo
tercero pues el gran desafío personal de
tratar de prevenir que la gente me
enfermara porque realmente nunca en mi
vida como médico de ha visto tantas
personas fallecer en tan poco tiempo ha
sido una historia de triunfos y derrotas
de lágrimas y de sonrisas pero es una
historia inolvidable en la vida de
cualquier doctor como cambió la vida
esta emergencia mundial
creo que el mundo y son un stop paro
y sufrió y nos dimos cuenta que somos
vulnerables que simplemente somos
habitantes de un planeta y que los roles
de superioridad no aplican cuando hay
una enfermedad que nos hace susceptible
a todos y que nos puede matar a todos
incluso siendo una enfermedad tan
dramática realmente la mortalidad es muy
pequeña no se imagina uno qué pasaría
con una pandemia donde la mortalidad
fuera mucho más alta
seguramente pues ese es el gran reto del
aprendizaje para prepararnos en un
futuro bueno y entonces es la vacuna la
gran esperanza para que todo esto acabe
usted ya la recibió
si es posible recibir felicidad
tranquilidad pero también en la
esperanza y el compromiso para que todos
lo reciban para que todos nos dediquemos
en el vacunemos siguiente es la más
grande herramienta para tener la
pandemia también tenemos que mantener la
prevención de los casos vacunación
siéntase celebración de casos no va a
funcionar por los linajes virales la
vacuna de la esperanza es el fin de la
pandemia y todos debemos vacunarlos
y un año después de esta declaración el
doctor cómo ve usted el ánimo de los
profesionales de la salud con los que
trabajan
es un nuevo ánimo cuando reciben la
vacuna es sin duda la alegría y la
tranquilidad para seguir trabajando es
inmensa sin embargo pues obviamente
están agotados muchas veces
desconcertados por lo que vemos en el
comportamiento que las personas nos
modifican y realmente creo que la
vacunación nos da un nuevo impulso para
seguir atendiendo a las personas pero
esto no se trata de atender con hoy
tenemos muchos más problemas de salud
que tenemos que afrontar en una gran
pandemia que es el cáncer las
enfermedades crónicas desatendidas y en
eso tenemos que enfocar el resto del año
también esperemos que pueda ser posible
y la última pregunta que le quiero hacer
es cuál es y en dónde han sido los
fracasos y los aciertos en la gestión de
esta pandemia
definitivamente como tener una pandemia
no lo sabemos estamos escribiendo el
libro pero hay ejemplos como lo que está
pasando en brasil que son lamentables en
la región donde los récord de
fallecimientos son los más altos en el
mundo y que realmente la perspectiva es
muy trágica en este par de meses que
vienen a continuación y tenemos ejemplos
de gestión muy interesante como lo que
pasa no a zelandia en australia en otras
latitudes donde hubo ejemplos de
liderazgo y del control de la enfermedad
esto no es una sólidas quién lo hace
mejor o quién lo hace peor cada uno lo
hizo lo mejor posible pero sin duda
tenemos que aprender reflexionar para
poder enfrentar estos problemas en un
futuro de una mejor forma
que así desea doctor y le deseo muchos
éxitos porque todavía quedan muchos
pacientes por atender y muchas vacunas
por aplicar hasta aquí cinco minutos con
ustedes de siga con nosotros y con toda
nuestra programación de france 24
[Música]